all right ernesto
ernesto where'd you grow up where are
you from uh queen's new york queens yeah
and tell me about your family you had uh
mom and dad growing up yeah
full family you know uh older sibling
mother father grandmother
um
yeah you know my my parents are hardcore
like conservative christians
so
like
we definitely were like kind of like
brought into that like to the extreme um
it was
it was kind of like conflicting because
uh you know if i was like
born in today's time i probably would
have been told i had like add or adhd or
something like that so i was like a very
hyperactive kid growing up um
and
you know like uh
family was uh family was tricky because
i have an older sibling that
is like no contact at all
like as of today uh and that's kind of
like part of the reason why
um
i feel like
i'm kind of the way i am is because i
had a lot of abuse from him growing up
as a child yeah he's a full brother huh
he's your full brother yeah full brother
and he's got he's out of the family now
well
my father owns the building complex we
live in he lives in the basement um
and but it's like two strangers like
no nothing like passing by yeah yeah
it's pretty bad
that's because it's because of why drugs
or
no he
he has anger issues for sure 100 he he
was always
getting in trouble in school he would
sometimes be some of the kids up from
church um
and i just happened to be the one at
home who you know i was basically like
the dog he kicked at the end of the end
of a hard day it felt like
um
yeah you know and it was it was it was
pretty bad it was really very bad um
like especially in the summers when we
were kids you know my mom would just be
like okay like you're everybody's at
work
take charge
um yeah and it was it was just
like
it was a bit
some i'm not gonna lie i was pretty
hyper child but most of them were kind
of uncalled for like they would just be
i don't know where he would just start
you know punching me smacking me
knocking me down like it was like every
other day you know
and um
i feel like it was a bit
much
and
you know i would never fight back i was
never that kind of i was never an
instigator i'm never like violent like
that
but did your parents protect you or
no because this was the deal it i
i didn't have a phone back then
this was like back in the day where the
only phone was the cord phone and the
walk in the kitchen
so you know whenever he would do
something and something would break we'd
break mirrors doors
um
windows like anything you can name it
and then
i would get you know he would i didn't
think i even knew my parent's number
back then that he would just call
and
say he started like he's acting up you
know like he's being hyper
um
so i kind of got like the reputation of
the i guess the problem child for the
most part yeah
so that that's what it was like with him
um no no
no difficulty with your parents
um
i was pretty close with my mom
i would say i'm still close it's just um
i feel like she puts her beliefs before
me
a lot of the time you know like she'll
maybe she'll side with somebody from the
church
as opposed to
how i feel about a certain topic you
know like
like
music is like a thing that she looks
down upon me or like you know like if
if i don't go to church or like you know
maybe certain things that she
thinks are like i guess a sinful
lifestyle in her eyes um my dad i'm not
really close with at all i don't really
talk to my dad
um
[Music]
which is it's unfortunate because
like my dad is a great guy like i love
my dad but
uh
he
[Music]
he's the kind of guy that everybody
loves and respects but he kind of lives
um
like our relationship isn't kind of like
what people have with him like what
people see
um
and he's you know both my parents like
my mom's a sunday school teacher and my
dad like he does like the camera work at
like you know the the media stuff at the
church
and you know
it kind of got to a point where like we
don't really even talk at all and like
that was kind of like normal to me like
it never bothered me but i i kind of
always questioned it i'm like you know
like when i would hear him like do his
prayers and like like he'd lead classes
for like bible studies and stuff like
that at the house and i'd just be like
you know this
it's interesting that
you know what my dad always like talks
to god but like he never like really
wants to talk to me you know so i kind
of found that like
a bit troubling you know um but i
practice the same faith and i i still
believe it like these things don't deter
me and i'm not like bashing any religion
like i i full wholeheartedly like
believe it and like practice it
um
you made it through high school
no
um so i
after a certain point i stopped being uh
an honor student like i was
in all these extracurricular activities
and like honest class and
i just
i guess i had like a switch a turning
point where i was just like you know if
i'm already getting treated this way
like let me just really act out so i
would get suspended i got kicked out of
uh engineering school um and then the
new school i just had no credit so i
just got kicked out yeah i got kicked
out yeah for what
just
acting out like it wasn't even like
fights or anything like that i was just
you know being disrespectful to teachers
or not going to class or just being at
the place i shouldn't be and then it was
just like you know like
you're basically doing nothing here like
this is a good school like we like won't
tolerate this this is like you know
so you were a troubled teenager
yeah
i would say just you know just a little
[__] you know but i wasn't like violent
or anything like that i never never got
into fights
and then the
the suicide attempts when did that start
uh when i was 17
yeah
so by then um i had dropped out
uh
like i was getting into like pretty like
severe fist fights at home i was getting
kicked out a lot
sometimes i would get kicked out like in
the middle of winter like with nothing
but like
shorts and a shirt that i had on like
literally just like get out of the house
um
and yeah like i would stay at friends
places i would there was this truck lot
that they had like the work campers in i
would stay there because i knew they
were open i stayed there a couple times
and left before the sunrise before
anybody came like stuff like that
um
yeah and so i'm 17 all this stuff is
happening and
i guess i kind of got it all like
bottled up
so to speak but i'm like pretty you know
i guess i'm pretty depressed about it
um
but i never thought it was something
like i thought like i needed to help
with because like
i guess i was like brought to believe
like like or some people in the church
are like
depression isn't real depression is a
demon
like you got to pray that depression
demon away
and i kind of believe it so to speak
like or like you know that's kind of how
i thought at that time i'm like okay
like it's just the feeling it's not like
i never thought it was something like
that was like you know clinical like
that could be like um wiring mixed up
brain chemistry yeah yeah stuff like
that
um so yeah i remember um there was just
this one girl i used to i had this job
at an after school
and
there was this one girl that i was just
like i basically like just fell in love
with like like
and like she became like my drug like i
wasn't doing anything i never didn't
drink at the time i didn't do drugs at
the time um i was just like ever my
whole like source of happiness like
every other problem that i had was just
like to the side like i just had this
one track mind towards this one person
um
but that was a pretty toxic relationship
it wasn't even a relationship that's
like the stupid part too it's it's um
[Music]
um
it's like a situationship you know it's
like oh like we're together but we're
not we're doing boyfriend and girlfriend
stuff but we're not boyfriend or
girlfriend
you know so
i'm like 16 at that time
when i met her
and
yeah like i just was head over heels
like i was like a lost puppy with her
and
you know like a year year and a half
into it like
you know we were like constantly talking
and like texting calling each other
you know like hanging out doing cool
stuff and you know she gave me the
indication that she you know wanted more
and then you know
one day she just kind of switched up
and she was like yo like
it's not gonna happen so
um i i like put way too much into this
one person then that i felt
every other thing that was going on in
my life just collapsed
so
i guess like that was like my first like
mental breakdown like
i thought like
what's the point
like it was such an emptiness that i was
just like yo like
like
like it's it's such like a thing that
you want to just turn off but you can't
like
it's like the thoughts that are coming
in are just constant and consistent that
it became like unbearable like even at
17.
so
like this is how like
like dumb i was back then i was just
like okay well let me go out like in
like such a dramatic way i guess
so
i went to the train station and like i
jumped on the tracks as the train was
coming in
and
i was just like so in my head about it i
just like i saw the train coming down
the tunnel this was like in like 74th
street and
roosevelt
and queen station and
um i see the train coming in and i just
know it's coming in hot and i'm like in
the middle of the platform so i'm just
like okay it's coming it's coming like i
hear it and i'm just like looking at the
track i was like i'm just gonna jump on
the tracks i'm just looking where i'm
gonna jump and i jump and the train was
probably like a good three four yards
away from hitting me like it stopped
like
pretty fast i was like i was actually
surprised but i feel bad for everybody
that kind of had to go through that
whiplash in the train but it's that fast
and
when i like actually landed on the
tracks and like it was still i was just
like
like what like what did i just do like
it was just
conductors saw you and stopped yeah yeah
yeah he was watching for sure
um and he
hit the brakes quick and then i was just
like [__] i was like i can't believe
like like i'm just in my hand like what
did i just do
um
so they yank me out
um i'm crying there's people around me
there's people screaming like oh my god
like what the heck what the heck
um
[Music]
a cop comes they handcuff me
and they take me to the psych ward for
the first time
so they take me there they evaluate me i
stay there for two weeks
and i say yeah i was like just going
through it
yeah and i i didn't even call my parents
when they were taking me and i called my
cousin
yeah like that's gives you an idea like
how just
not
[Music]
in communications with my parents just i
just i just called my cousin i was like
yo like i'm in hospital i'm going to the
hospital
because i was you know
going through through a phone like
breakdown did they
did they
give you any psych medications or
anything like that do they treat you in
any way
i think they gave me an antidepressant
which i didn't take
i didn't take i was very anti-medicine i
was very anti-therapy too
just the idea of going to talk to
somebody about my problems was like i
don't need that
like
i was kind of brought up to just kind of
like just deal with it
you know that that's kind of been my
mentality for like a long long time
has that changed now yeah
yeah oh yeah
yeah because
this most recent suicide
like i did it and i feel
like everybody knows like everybody
because if you're around me like
yo you're like you you can tell like wow
like
like you're really bad and i'll kind of
like i'll tell you like like i've been
open about it like yo like
i can't like go out now and like put a
front basically if somebody asked me how
am i like like i'll tell you
like i'll tell you like everything
basically for the most part like if you
really want to know you know if somebody
comes up to me say oh how are you i'm
like fine good but like somebody's like
actually stops being like yo like
really like how are you like what's
going on with you
like i'll tell you because it's just
been
this last
i guess episode has just been like hands
down like by far the worst crippling
depression like panic attack inducing
like just
like really bad so it's still going on
oh yeah i mean like i struggle with it
like i really do like every day like
since
since um
my last attempt in march like it's just
been a struggle it's really been like
it's like every day like i wake up and
it's like hell like i just wanted to
just
how old do you know 25. you're 25 yeah
so for
eight years or so you've been how many
attempts have you made um
seriously i want to say serious attempts
like serious serious attempts three like
half-assed ones like maybe another three
on top of that just taking pills like
taking all my empty depressing pills but
that in my opinion that's like kind of
half-assed you know like i feel like the
extreme ones were
trained one
the second one was when i slipped my
wrist i have four lashes up here
like very very very deep
um and is that one of the scars right
there in here yeah this one well this
one on the side here is more you have a
whole bunch more underneath it no this
one yeah these four right here
was the one the second one like the
second serious one this one was more
recent this one's fresh
so
that was that one and this most recent
one where i
i drove my car
and i basically just crashed it on the
side of the road and the highway wall
barrier the concrete one yeah so i still
got the you know that's that's why
you're that's why i got the boot on
right now yeah
so i mean what what is the
give her do you have some
excuse for why your
the the most recent attempt happened
it's not the girl anymore no yeah
all my triggers
seem to be the same
triggers it's always relationships
though but there's a different girl now
it's a different girl yeah yeah um
so
they recently diagnosed me with having
bpd which is by um
no yeah borderline personality disorder
some of the symptoms include um
self-destructive behavior self-harm
um
impulsiveness risk-taking behaviors
depression anxiety
um
[Music]
lack of self-worth um you know stuff
like that and it's it's
it's kind of like bipolar they're kind
of like cousins to each other
um but mine
mine my triggers kind of seem to be
definitely relationships like everything
could be crumbling around me but as if i
devote myself to one person
um
[Music]
and like my feelings basically fluctuate
based on that relationship if it's
a good or bad day with that person like
that'll be the determining like factor
of the day you know or my feelings could
switch like like that like you know
really quick have you had successful
romantic relationships no
not since the first one i feel like
the first one wasn't very successful nah
nah i feel like ever since that i've had
commitment issues
that
it made me feel like um
that if i don't fully commit i can't get
hurt
you know
um and that makes it difficult yeah oh
yeah yeah because i've been with girl
like you know i've gone out with girls
it's it's just like yo what are we doing
you know after like a couple months in
it's like okay like
is is there anything more and
i kind of just shy away you know like i
just i because i know how i am if i like
get really into somebody
because if i get into somebody like into
like being with somebody
um
[Music]
that scares me because it's like yo like
this is not like i'm not in control of
how i feel
and i'm not in control of my actions
when i feel a certain way you know what
i mean
and you've seen psychiatrists about this
or oh yeah yeah and you've been on med
medications um yeah yeah can they help
nah i mean it's a slow process
you know like they just switched um one
more recently
um
yeah i don't know i feel like that the
medicine sometimes i feel like they're
just
throwing a dart at a wheel and seeing
with sticks because it's not like i
could take a test like a blood test and
they say oh you got this you got that
you got that and just here take this
drug that's specific for that like they
have to test a lot of drugs on you and i
feel like like a you know like a lab rat
basically just being tested with all
these drugs
um
i've been to the psych ward three times
this year already
and they've like given me just different
stuff every time
you know and nothing has really helped
your situation no
no
and you're working
uh not really
uh i have or i made like a photography
studio in queens and i there i also did
my i saw puppets like i make and sell
puppets and i kind of just sell it off
there and
it's a very
like
specific niche market i guess
and you know i kind of just make my
bread there like that's where i make
most of my income
have you considered what what might help
you i mean
if medications aren't going to do the
trick then something there must be
something
do you think it's related somehow you
know different but related to your
brother's
mental situation
i think it's different um
i wouldn't
blame
my i guess disorder
on anybody else but i think no i'm just
wondering if something's genetic
is in your family well well yeah my dad
has you know his issues too and then
there was another family member that you
know had issues too like and suffered
with depression um i don't i kind of
don't want to get a tutu into that
because i don't think it's my story to
tell
um but there is you know
it seems to be genetic
um
and with bpd it also starts it
depends also on the upbringing as well
so i feel um
i could have had genetics and then it
could have been reinforced with also how
how i was raised or you know right
combination of the two yeah the
foundation for sure definitely but it's
common sense and
pep talks and things like that aren't
really effective are they no no like
it's like you're young you're handsome
you have everything to live for and all
that kind of stuff doesn't doesn't
impact your situation at all yeah
you can't tell me nothing you can't you
can't tell me nothing like
um
[Music]
i i always feel like
i'm very good at
finding things to die for
but i never really felt like i've found
reasons to live or things to live for
you know what do you think the solution
is
is it brain some
one day you'll find the medication that
helps your brain chemistry i i don't
know
i don't know
you know it
i i want to think i was doing
some sort of progress at the end like
you know after i got out of the hospital
i was like okay
i was like she's not in my life i still
care deeply about her but she's she's
not in it
yeah i found out um
she was actually been with somebody else
since the beginning of the year yeah but
i'm not going to tell you there are
other women out there in the world
because
it's not it's not about reason it's
about something going on in your head
yeah no no yeah and my thing is is
i never i don't really have like a dream
job like i never had like an inspiration
to do something like kids want to be
like oh i want to be a cop or i want to
be a doctor a lawyer whatever like i
always felt like i just wanted to share
my life with somebody like i don't care
if i'm like you know picking up
garbage in the side of the road or at
the park you know like as long as i'm
with somebody i'm happy like yeah for
sure like that sounds great to me
you know
um
but it you know
it's it's it's frustrating because i
feel like there's only
in my head like the way i'm at right now
it seems like there's only two solutions
and or two outcomes to this it's it's
it's either this happens again like i
get better and it just happens again and
it's
i don't think i can do it again you know
i don't think i could do this again
i have another one of these it's just
or
i
realize this and i grow old by myself
you know and
so you're still young yeah and
sometimes your brain chemistry mellows
changes
as you get older
you know i could see i could see you at
looking back at this time of your life
going man i can't believe i was i was
like that
or 35 or something i can't you can't oh
you you haven't seen it yet because
you've you've been you've been like this
your whole
yeah adult life yeah
it's like i i don't i don't i don't
really know if i can like trust anybody
again you know
right no it's pretty pretty extreme what
you what you are going through
yeah and you know
just not just
depressed over losing your girl
yeah it might be intense for sure but my
i don't know man it's like
it's like okay like again like i say
like i'm not gonna force anybody to be
with me who doesn't want to be with me
but it's like
you know during like all this time like
that i was going through it like
and i needed
you specifically to be there for me
like
everybody's been saying like it's gonna
be okay it's gonna be okay
like and uh you know
i'm not buying that
like
i just i was just i just wanted her to
just tell me like can you just tell me
because if you tell me like i'll believe
it like i will feel okay just by you
saying i understand it would be nice if
she
came to your rescue and all that but i
think there's a deeper problem than
that relationship
um
but at this point you're still healing
from the last attempt
do you have hope of of getting past this
i don't know
it's tough to live with this
every day yeah
yeah oh man
you know i feel like a burden too to
people
you know
like i like
this most recent one like i
i've been reaching out to people because
i can't i can't be alone
i can't be alone
you know
i find myself in like very questionable
places you know
drinking during the day
going out and are drugs or alcohol a big
part of your life
alcohol is a recently yeah yeah oh yeah
like just getting pissed board drunk
yeah
because i can't cope
i can't cope
alcohol is not gonna be the answer no
yeah and i know it i know it too i i
know it's a foolish thing
it's just i don't really
don't really know what to do
you know
like the escape is just
this seems impossible even with alcohol
because i always end up thinking hard
about it you know because it is a
depressant
after all yeah for sure
[Music]
that's an alarming situation you're in
yeah oh yeah this is not just like
you're depressed and it sucks no no no
no
you know
and i you know i i try to keep a smile
like i do
it's like lately is i find it hard to
and not that your family is going to
help much but do they know
yeah they know
but like i said it is very very taboo
[Music]
um so taboo to the point where
when i slipped my wrist and it was
bleeding out a lot
the only conversation i ever had with my
mom about it she just came into my room
she says do you need help cleaning it up
and i said no
that's it
you know
and that's not to say my mom don't love
me i love my mom but it how do you
how do you kind of just come to grips
with like your sons like suicidal you
know it's like
like what am i to do like this isn't
like in them
some sort of handbook i can read or you
know some sort of self-help book or
mothering guide or whatever parenting
book
or but our honestly maybe i feel it's
like some sort of like denial you know
now more recently she's more
understanding of it for sure
but she's always been i guess in denial
about it for sure yeah i would think
there's some
brain chemistry
so you know
thing behind all of this
[Music]
yeah
you just haven't found the right
medication yet or
or something needs to shift or change
yeah well you know
i've been taking dialectical behavior
therapy and
i think this week i out of all the
sessions i've had for the past few
months i think this week in particular
was a pretty
i guess
breakthrough if you will that's great
yeah yeah
you know
it was just
you know it's always intense because
like i try to keep things bottled up as
of recently just because you know i
don't want to be a drag or anything but
like
like every time i go to therapy like i'm
like bawling out in tears or crying or
just worked up about something but i
feel like you feel better afterwards
i feel good during
yeah when i leave it's like it's back at
it like back to how i'm thinking
you know but i think this was the one
time where i was like
i walked out of it and i was like okay i
feel i feel okay
i feel okay
[Music]
but like i said i think i don't know
where
like what's it all mean like i still
like i feel just empty like just i got
like i feel like i just have no purpose
honestly like nothing like i'm
like i don't know i just feel like i had
no worth like no self-worth at all
so
have you considered
doing work or
you know working working with people
that are in need of help and helping you
doing things for others basically
because sometimes that goes a long way
yeah by changing your
because this is this is basically self
you know you're looking at yourself too
much
and you're focusing on yourself so much
that you just get depressed
yeah well you know i focus on others i
think you'd probably loosen up maybe you
would be so hard on yourself yeah maybe
i don't know like look like stuff like
this kind of like
look i'm not gonna sit here and be like
i'm like
telling my story because i want people
like if it helps other people bring it
to light even better but
you know like i feel good about that for
sure but like
you know i i just feel open about it
like and i just
i feel like
i came here just because i wanted to be
heard like i feel like i've never really
been heard
like growing up
or just from anybody you know yeah like
i've never been heard
and
like
okay cool like my parents might not see
this okay cool i have no problem with
that this girl might not see it
cool i don't care it's like there's no
problem but like i just wanted to put it
out there just to be heard
i think there's other people probably
going through similar things
yeah oh yeah
yeah
and i feel for them like i wouldn't wish
this upon my worst enemy like at all
because
i feel like i like i'm not supposed to
like be this way
like there's just the part of my brain
where i feel like it's just like the
king
you know like i feel too much i feel way
too much yeah
all right
vanessa thank you so much for sharing
your story yeah appreciate it hopefully
i'll help somebody else and maybe it'll
help you somehow yeah for sure i hope
you figure it out yeah
me too all right man thank you very much
cool
you